the Jim Gaffigan show renewed for a
second season congratulation enjoying
yourself it's fun and you know it's it's
a lot of work and my wife and I Jeanne
you know we're we're working really hard
and I thank you to everyone who's
watched by the way watch if you didn't
watch don't worry it just means you're a
bastard it's hard to get because it's so
fragmented now right there's so many you
know wages yes and episodes and shows
that are disposable it's overwhelming
there's like a pressure and you know
there's a pressure because we all have
developed excuses for our friends like
we're dealing with debt collectors you
know it's like have you watched true
detective I'm catching up give me a week
baby you know it's never ending and you
binge watch right I binge watch shows I
don't even like I'm like well this is
pretty bad I guess I watched eight more
episode I watched every episode of True
Blood and I'm not even gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
doesn't mean you're gay that's cuz
you're gay wait strange when you get
done with this serious like you you
don't know what to do you feel lost
you're like I haven't been this long
since the ending of loss and starting a
new show it's kind of like a blind date
you're like well my friend said you were
great I'm free tonight we could get to
know each other
relationship that's why when people
watch the show I'm so grateful cuz it
it's like a relationship like breaking
up with the show that happens you know
you're like it's over you know I gave up
the best nights of my life for you but
Netflix it won't let you forget you know
they'll keep them in your queue yeah
since you enjoy True Blood here's some
other gay show hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please